ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE IS
CALLED TO WORK. GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY. HOMEGOING CALLED IT
PRECAUTIONS MASTER REQUIRED FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING
THROUGHOUT AND THROUGHOUT
CAPITOL GROUNDS. YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN PERSON BY TELEPHONE
OR REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
OUTSIDE OF THE CAPITAL. THE
NUMBER TO CALL IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWENTY FOUR. TWO SIX TWO.
THIRTY SEVEN. THIS NUMBER CAN
BE FOUND ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND IS DISPLAYED ON
YOUR SCREENS. FOR THOSE CALLING
IN PLEASE MAKE YOURSELVES WHILE
IN THE QUEUE TO ELIMINATE
BACKGROUND NOISE. REACH BILL
HEARD TODAY THERE WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. AND TWO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. TO EACH PROVIDED
TWO MINUTES OF TESTIMONY. FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES CALLING IN
YOU WILL BE PLACED IN A QUEUE
UNTIL YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE. PUBLIC COMMENT.
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
ALTERNATED. WHEN IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT
PRESS ONE. THEN ZERO AND UNMUTE
YOURSELF IN ORDER TO SPEAK.
PLEASE BE BRIEF LIMITING YOUR
COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FRAZIER HERE BIGELOW.
AGUIAR-CURRY BERMAN. BRIAN
COOLEY COOPER. DALY DAVIES
GALLAGHER GARCIA GIPSON JONES
SAWYER LACKEY LOW MATHIS.
QUICKSILVER RAMOS. THREE OF US.
RUBIO SALAS SMITH. WITH A
QUORUM. OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR TIMELY
ATTENDS THE STORY OF PRECIADO.
IN THE ON TIME CAUCUS- FOR
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND HOUSEKEEPING
WILL **** FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX HAVE
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B. EIGHT
ONE EIGHT HAS BEEN PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR. AND I'D LIKE TO-
WELCOME. THE ILLUSTRIOUS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ISAAC BRING TO
THE ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. SO HOW-
ENTERTAIN A- A MOTION ON SB
THREE OH TWO SB EIGHT NINETEEN
SB EIGHT TWENTY AND ALL THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION BILLS WE HAVE A
FIRST BY. MISTER SMITH S.
SECOND BY MR COOLEY- SO WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER HERE
ARE YES HI FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN BERMAN
HI BRIAN BRIAN I COOLEY. COOLEY
AYE COOPER. COOPER AYE DALY.
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
GALLAGHER GARCIA GIPSON JONES
SAWYER LACKEY LOW MATHIS
QUICKSILVER RAMOS RAMOS HI
RIVAS THREE OF US I RUBIO.
SALAS SALAS I SMITH. SMITH I.
WE HAVE THIRTEEN LEAVE IT OPEN
WE WILL. FOR ABSENT MEMBERS SO
AUTHOR- SENATOR GLAZERS. SB
NINETEEN. YOU HAVE NOT VERY
VERY SUPPORTIVE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE PRESENTER WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU UP MISTER CHAIRMAN IS
THE MICROPHONE WORKING. THE
MICROPHONE WORKING. CAN YOU
HEAR ME MISTER CHAIRMAN. VERY
WELL. I CAN TALK REALLY LOUD
YOU KNOW COME ON UP HERE TO MY
MIND. PLEASE YEAH IF THEY CAN
TURN IT ON. TRY THIS ONE HERE
NOW THIS IS WORKING YEAH A
TERRIFIC OKAY THANK YOU SORRY-
FUTURE EMPLOYMENT AT THIS CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK U. S. B. NINETEEN
WOULD ALLOW WILL WANT LICENSE
WINE AND BRANDY MANUFACTURES TO
HAVE TO OFF SITE TASTING ROOMS
UNDER EXISTING LAW TYPE TWO ONE
GROVER LICENSEES ARE ALLOWED TO
TASTING ROOMS ONE ON SITE AT
THE PRODUCTION FACILITY AND A
SECOND ONE OFF SITE. OUT WHEN I
TOWARD MY DISTRICTS- WINE
REGION AND I HAVE ABOUT SIXTY
WINERIES IN MY AREA MOST OF
THEM VERY SMALL ONE THING I
KEPT HEARING WAS THAT MANY
WINERIES ARE STRUGGLING TO
OPERATE UNDER ALTERNATING
PROPRIETORSHIP AGREEMENTS WHICH
ALLOW WINE MAKER TO PRODUCE
THEIR WINE AT ANOTHER WINERIES
PRODUCTION FACILITIES HIS
AGREEMENTS ARE OFTEN USED BY
SMALL FAMILY OWNED WINERIES
THAT DON'T HAVE THE FACILITIES
TO PROCESS. THEIR OWN GRAVES.
WHEN A WINERY ENTERS INTO THESE
AGREEMENTS THEY MUST USE THEIR
MASTER LICENSE. AND THE
ACCOMPANYING RIGHT TO AN ON
SITE TASTING ROOM TO COVER THE
BORROWED FACILITY AND
PRACTICES ALMOST ALWAYS MEANS
THAT THE WINERIES OPERATING
UNDER THESE AGREEMENTS ARE
PROHIBITED FROM HAVING A
TASTING ROOM AT THEIR
PRODUCTION FACILITY SINCE THE
HOST WINERY USUALLY ISN'T
WILLING TO SHARE THEIR TASTING
ROOM WITH THE- LEASING WINERY.
IN ADDITION TO THIS SPECIFIC
PROBLEM FOR WINERIES IN
ALTERNATING PROPRIETORSHIPS.
THE INTEL ENTIRE CALIFORNIA
WINE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
CHALLENGED BY BILLIONS OF LOST
REVENUE AND DAMAGES FROM THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
WILDFIRES. ALL CALIFORNIA
WINERIES BIG AND SMALL WOULD
BENEFIT BY GIVING THEM THE
OPTION TO OPEN ONE MORE OFF
SITE TASTING ROOM. SMALL
WINERIES IN ALTERNATING
PROPRIETORSHIPS WOULD HAVE A
SECOND TASTING ROOM WHILE
LARGER WINERIES WOULD STILL
HAVE THE INCENTIVE TO INVEST IN
THEIR OWN PRODUCTION
FACILITIES. THIS ALLOW ALL
WINERIES TO PLAY ON THE SAME
PLAYING FIELD FOR PROVIDING
SUPPORT FOR SMALL WINERIES RELY
HEAVILY ON DIRECT SALES TWO
TASTING ROOMS. IMPORTANTLY THIS
BILL PRESERVES LOCAL CONTROL
BECAUSE- BECAUSE THE NEW
TASTING ROOMS WOULD STILL NEED
COME TO COMPLY WITH ALL LOCAL
ZONING. REQUIREMENTS WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY ARE TIM SCHMELZER
IN THE WINE INSTITUTE. AND
STEVE THERE IS A- FROM THE
STEVEN KENT WINERY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZER SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THOSE IN THE GALLERY. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TO SPEAK.
SEEING NONE. WE'LL ASK THOSE IN
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK TO THE BILL
ADMINISTRATION AND I HAD TO
WITNESSES THAT MAYBE THEY'RE ON
THE PHONE LINES THAT WERE I
THOUGHT SCHEDULED TO TESTIFY-
I'M NOT THERE YET. NO NO NO NO
GO TO THE IDEA. SO WILL GO TO-
THE- REMOTE TESTIMONY ST
STATION I'LL GET TO CATCH. ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
REMOTE TEST TESTIMONY STATION.
HEARING NONE. WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE PHONES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OPERATOR. GIVE
MODERATE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINETY. IF YOU'RE PART OF SB
NINETEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND ANY WITNESSES
MADE. YOU HAVE AN OPEN LINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
STEVEN CAN'T BEAR A SOUP SIX
GENERATION WINEMAKER AND
SHOULDN'T TELL THE LINEAGE
COLLECTION LOCATED IN THE
HISTORIC LIVERMORE VALLEY. I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR GLAZER
AND HIS TEAM FOR THEIR MUCH
NEEDED SUPPORT FOR SMALL WIND
RESEARCH IS MINE. ALMOST 85% OF
ALL WHINERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
CLASSIFIED AS SMALL WHICH
GENERALLY MAKES THEM UNSUITABLE
FOR WIDE SCALE WHOLESALE
DISTRIBUTION. THESE WINERIES
NEED THEIR TASTING ROOMS IN
ORDER TO SURVIVE COMPETITIVE
BUSINESS. ABOUT 75% OF MY SALES
ORDER WINE CLUB MEMBERS AND THE
GENERAL PUBLIC. AND THE
PANDEMIC OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN
MONTHS IS PROOF THAT DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SALES ARE ABSOLUTELY
CRUCIAL. TO OUR SURVIVAL. AS A
WIDELY WITH THE GPS. I ONLY
HAVE LEGAL ACCESS TO ONE
TASTED. WHICH PUTS ME IN MIND
THESE ARE QITE A LARGE
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE.
PASSAGE OF SB NINETEEN WOULD
EVEN THE PLAYING FIELD AND
ALLOW THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMPETE OR FAVORABLY. THOUSANDS
OF OTHER WHITE LOCAL TASTING
ROOMS. ALL PEACEKEEPERS ARE
GOVERNED BY STATE AND LOCAL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS. BECAUSE
OF THIS AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF PATIENTS ON WILL BE
HANDLED RESPONSIBLY. AND THEN
ORGANIZED FASHION. FOR THE SAKE
OF SMALL FAMILY OWNED BY
GENERATIONAL PURPOSES LIKE MINE
I. REFUSE TO PASS SB NINETEEN.
VERY MUCH- GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JIM SCHMELZER
WITH WINE INSTITUTE- I LIKEWISE
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER A SINCERE
APPRECIATION TO SENATOR GLAZERS
BRENT DOCTORED TARGET EFFORTS
TO GET THIS POLICY AN ACTIVE WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL SURE- ASSET
SENATOR NOTED IT'S BEEN A VERY
TOUGH YOUR FOR A CALIFORNIA
SMALL WINERIES- THEY'RE ALMOST
WHOLLY DEPENDENT ON THEIR
TEACHING ROOMS AS A MEANS TO
INTERACT WITH THEIR CUSTOMERS
AND SELL THEIR PRODUCTS. WITH
THIS PAST YEAR'S CLOSURES AND
RESTRICTIONS THEIR ABILITY TO
DO BUSINESS WITH SEVERELY
COMPROMISED SB NINETEEN S.
BEFORE YOU OTHER TERRIFIC TIME
TO HELP SPUR THE RECOVERY FOR
CALIFORNIA WINERIES BY
OPPORTUNITY DECISIONAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO CONNECT
WITH THEIR CUSTOMERS WITH THE
ABILITY TO OPEN AN ADDITIONAL
OFF SITE TASTING ROOM WINERIES
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LOCATE AND MORE CONVENIENT.
LOCATIONS FOR THE CUP. NOTABLY
THIS OP WILL PROVEN. TO THOSE
WINERIES THAT ARE IN WILD FIRES
OR- IF THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
MAKE USE OF THIS ADDITIONAL
TASTING ROOM TO CONTINUE TO DO
THAT THE CURRENT TIMES IN WHICH
THEIR WINERY MAY BE AN
ACCEPTABLE. WINERY TASTING
ROOMS ENJOY A STRONG
REPUTATION. AS SOUTHWEST MEANT.
MODIFY CONSTRUCTION ENERGY
CONTRIBUTORS THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL LANDSCAPE. WE STRONGLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY FOR US
THE NINETEEN EFFORTS TO FURTHER
THIS EXPERIENCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. WATERY OR
DO WE HAVE ANY. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL- WE STILL
HAVE SOME SUPPORT IN THE QUEUE.
SO WE CAN GO WE WILL GO TO
LIVE. I'D LIKE TO GO TO THE
OPPOSITION FIRST AS THE
WITNESSES THEN WE'LL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY ANY
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION. IS
THERE ANY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION. I DO
NOT HEAR ANY WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR THEN
WE'LL CHECK THE COMMENTS ON THE
ON THE BILL PLEASE. THANK YOU.
IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE OF THEIR
APPEARANCE BORDER OPPOSITION OF
SB NINETEEN. AND WE WILL GO
LINE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY FINE FOURTEEN DISAPPEARED
YOU'LL HAVE TO START YOU'LL
HAVE TO PUSH ONE AND THEN ZERO
AGAIN. NEXT OVER THE LINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS TIM LYNCH
FROM PLATINUM ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF THE NAPA VALLEY
VINTNERS AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. NINETEEN AND THANK THE
SENATOR FOR. THANK YOU AND LINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SHARON MEMBERS
MELISSA HI ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY WINEMAKERS OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND AGAIN I'VE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF SB NINETEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING VALERIE NERA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINETEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CARE WE HAVE NO FURTHER
WITNESSES ARE- PUBLIC COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HELP MODERATOR
PERSIAN. WE DO HAVE ONE OF THE
COMMON IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME WHO YOU'RE
REPRESENTING AND YOUR SUPPORT
FOR OPPOSITION. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRIS MY KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR GLAZERS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
STILL GOING TO COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS OF FROM THE- FROM THE
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MISTER. BIGELOW FIRST. SENATOR
I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS ON
YOU MIGHT. SENATOR MARCO
POLITIES- APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS ON THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT BEING ONE
OF THOSE WITH A LARGE VAST
ARRAY OF- WINERIES IN HIS
DISTRICT I BE PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS IF YOU WOULD BE
SO KIND. THANK YOU DISCOVER THE-
FOR. SENATE OUR THANKS FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- I
LIKED IT SO MUCH MORE PROUD CO
AUTHOR- IT'S STILL PORTER
PRESENT MODI WHICH GROWS ABOUT
20% OF THE WINE IN CALIFORNIA
THEY'VE GOT EIGHTY FIVE
WINERIES AND WILSON WERE FAMILY
OWNED WINERIES THEY AREN'T IN
COSCO OR RETARDED OR OTHER
PLACES- THEY'RE TRYING TO SELL
IT AND JUST TRYING TO GET AHEAD
THIS IS VERY HELPFUL TO THEM
AND THEIR BUSINESSES AND JUST
TO GET ONE OUT THERE MORE MOST
AND SURVIVE ONLINE CLUB
MEMBERS. I'M A MEMBER FOR
SEVERAL CLUBS DOWN THERE AND-
THEY DO A GOOD JOB DOING THAT
AND IT'S TOUGH- DURING BUSINESS
SOMETIMES- CALIFORNIA SOMETHING
WE CAN DO TO HELP MORE
CALIFORNIA ONCE APPRECIATED
STILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING THIS AWFUL BILL FORWARD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AGAIN THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZERS BRING THIS
BILL FOR- I REPRESENT TO THE
NEWMAN LAKE NAPA AND THIS IS A
VERY WELL INTENTIONED BILL I
REALLY APPRECIATE BRING FORTH
IN DURING THE PANDEMIC WE HAD
TO PUT A LOT IN OUR FAMILY FOR
OUR WINEMAKERS REALLY DID AN
INCREDIBLE JOB OF MAKING SURE
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO BE IN
BUSINESS BUT I GIVEN UP ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FLEXIBILITY IS
REALLY IMPORTANT I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS FORWARD. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OF
THE OFFER FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER BUSH WOULD LIKE CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR THE KIND COMMENTS- THIS
MORNING I'VE VISITED MANY OF
YOUR AREAS AND ENJOYED THE- THE
BOUNTY OF YOUR- WONDERFUL-
PROPRIETORS IN THE WONDERFUL
SOIL THAT- THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
STATE I WANT TO THANK THAT.
MIGHT MY CO AUTHORS HERE ON THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND AS A MEMBER
COOPER AND- THAT THE VICE CHAIR
FOR HIS- IT IT. WILLINGNESS TO
JOIN AS WELL AND AS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT OF.
SO I BELIEVE WE HAD A FIRST BY
YOUR CURRY SECOND BY- SIMILAR
DAVIS- SENATOR GLAZERS I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THE STRIFE THAT HAS
BEEN INFLICTED ON THE WINE
INDUSTRY AND THE SMALL WINERIES
AND SMALL BOUTIQUE WINERIES- WE
TALK ABOUT THE PANDEMIC OF FACT
WE ALSO FORGET ABOUT THE
WILDFIRES AND THE SMOKE COULD
DAMAGE CROPS AND DEVASTATED
CROPS GOING ON SO ANYTHING THAT
WE CAN DO TO FACILITATE AND
HELP BRING THAT INDUSTRY A
SMALL. POINT INDUSTRY ALL ALSO
THE BIG BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL AFTER
SUCH A DEVASTATING LOSS AND-
AND HARM- THAT I APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THIS- ADVANTAGE IN
MAKING THAT HAPPEN I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
I COULDN'T DO IT BEFOREHAND
BECAUSE OF BEING THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE WHEN TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT HAD A- UNBIASED
LOOK AT IT- BUT ALSO
UNDERSTANDING THAT IN MY
DISTRICT. WE HAVE SYSOON VALLEY-
WHICH SHOULD BE RATED AS THE
NEXT NAPA VALLEY. SO THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH- AND WITH THAT.
MASSACRE TERRY WILL CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM ONE S. B.
NINETEEN THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRAZIER PARK
FRAZIER AYE BIGELOW. HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BERMAN BERMAN I COOLEY. COOLEY
I. BRIAN BRIAN I YEAH COOPER I
COOPER AYE DALY DALY AYE DAVIES.
DAVIES I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
AYE GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON AYE
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY BLACKIE I
LOW. HELLO HI MATHIS. CORK
SILVA A QUICK SILVA I'D ALMOST.
RAMESSIDE RIVAS. RIVERSIDE
RUBIO RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I
SMITH SMITH I. HAS NINETEEN.
YOUR VOTE HAS YOUR BILL IS
NINETEEN IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AGAIN GOOD LUCK WITH IT IN
THE FUTURE I WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
TWO YOU'RE WELCOME TO STAY IN
VISIT POOR. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH SEE YOU NEXT WEEK MR YES
CAN WE- OPEN THE ROLE FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR LET'S GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE ROLE PERHAPS THE
MEMBERS NOW SO YOU CAN LEAVE
AND THEN WE'LL WAIT FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
AYE GARCIA. GIPSON GIPSON I
JONES SAWYER. LACKEY LACKEY I
LOW LOW HI MATHIS RICK SILVA.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR QUIRK
SILVA. XLVII ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR RUBIO RUBIO I'D
CONSENT CALENDARS OUT.
READY
OKAY MISTER MATHIS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MATHIS I.
MISTER MATHIS ON FILE ITEM ONE
S. B. NINETEEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. MATHIS
I.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI.
FILE ITEM ONE S. B. NINETEEN
THE MOTION IS DO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'M.
THIS
CONCLUDES THE GOVERNMENTAL
OPERATIONS- COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY. CORDIER.